[Musique]
croyez vous qu'il y ait de pata plus je
ne vous trompez pas voter bien sûr photo
world.com attention isolement
[Musique]
ils sortiront pas aujourd'hui que c'est
agaçant
so lu ment que je trouve le moyen de les
faire sortir mais dis moi dix makram ou
chocolat doit être cuite après blanc ou
et que je dois mettre mon collier rouge
où mon collier vert
quelle horreur
ça alors j'ai compris c'est le 1er avril
brassant d'avril je vous ai bien tous
attrapé par les pattes a plus qu'est ce
que c'est que ça rien du tout
le secteur est devenu pour cause après
oui monsieur le recteur
[Musique]
est pas top le truc direct
la cia
[Musique]
m
parce que tout
[Musique]
et
je ne sauront jamais acquis ce paquet
est destiné n'avait pas de parti et pas
de facteurs non plus quoi approcher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je serais curieux on dirait qu'il se
rend compte de rien bon d'un sac à
papier
j'aimerais le coeur net qu'est ce que
c'est que ça une crème au poids fond
rouge un plat avec fait la patte à coeur
mais vous êtes tout noir
si les nouvelles modes mais si vous
quand c'est joli mais pas vous tenaille
je ne m'en sépare jamais surtout pour
déjeuner c'est très commode je ne me
sens pas très bien je vais remonter chez
moi au revoir et bien 3g vous qu'il y
ait de pâtes a péché qui ne vous trompez
pas
notez bien sur vos droits au hasard
patrocle aux attentes il en manque un
[Musique]